poverty is pushing kids down the wrong
path
with the current cost of living crisis
making matters worse than ever
children as young as 11 adjoining gangs
to make money for some it's to help put
food on the table while their parents
turn a blind eye
the voices of the young people we've
spoken to have been changed to protect
their safety
if he's got
no food on the table and providing for
himself and his family
i can't blame him for that
i went to manchester to meet this 17
year old
at the age of just 14 he became the
breadwinner for his family
by selling class a drugs it was you as
you and your friends you were 14 and you
sold weed then how did that progress and
escalate the weed wasn't making that
much money
so i had to sell other stuff
such as crack
cocaine
heroin
other stuff
at what ages was that happening
it was happening like the age of 14 to
15. it's shocking
so young drug dealing walking the
streets of a knife
but he felt he had no choice
i had to be the man of the house
like
i don't have an older brother to protect
me
i don't have a younger brother to
protect me
i don't have no one
i've got two little siblings which i
have to protect no one else my family is
never at home
so i grew up quick
make money for him provide for my family
that's how it works
would your parents ever ask you about
the money that was coming in or the
things you're able to buy for them and
your siblings i used to tell him it was
legit
i used to tell him i got a job what job
did you tell him just tell them i had a
job around the corner corner shop that's
it with living costs surging he says
more young people than ever are taking
the same path he did
living's gone up
to even living this country is expensive
so what is it for them to do
sell drugs
make money quick
without waiting
but quick decisions have lasting
consequences
a few weeks before filming
his friend was stabbed to death in front
of him
i want to talk to you about some murder
case
have you ever heard of a guy called
no i don't think so
when was he killed
he says he's fine
but how could he be
the person who helped him change his
life was matthew norford a youth worker
from manchester and just give him some
self
motivation skills i've come to meet him
because he says the forgotten victims of
this crisis are children already living
in poverty
they don't want to have no heating on
they don't want to go to school and be
bullied because they've not got the
latest clothes or just normal clothes
you know what i hear the mum crying the
little sister when it's a birthday and
there's no food and they're going to a
food bank i would have a lot of families
now that are on food bank and a lot of
families whereas you talk to them
they're not getting a birthday cake and
they tell you because i know my mom's
got no money and a human moon cried that
breaks my heart
no kids should be leaving like or having
to go to school just to get fed some of
the reasons what made me sell drugs
because we were living in poverty
and who did i talk to
who you tell me who did i talk to
there's no one to talk to someone like
me but how many i can't reach hundreds
of thousands of kids that's happened to
every year
those concerns not just being felt in
manchester but the west midlands too
here the assistant police and crime
commissioner has written to the
government asking them to intervene
sometimes you have a household where
parent or parents are working two jobs
just so that can keep up with the rent
or food to put food on the table and
that can leave children and young people
vulnerable to being exploited by adults
who see that they're left alone and want
to pull them into their way of life
these children are desperate listen to
this ex-gang member from birmingham he's
barely out of school
this crisis is making basic necessities
like washing too expensive to afford
you're mentioning the kettle baths and a
bit of those sorts of things yeah when
the heating went out having kettle baths
it would be like for four hours you're
trying to fill up the bath with the
kettle and it's not all the way full up
and stuff like that by the time you get
in the bath the water is probably cold
and plus there was no heating so then
there was
it wasn't really an ideal situation for
anyone
he has now found the help he needs to
stay off the streets
others he knows not so lucky
you mentioned uh
a teenager who got stabbed in the back
recently what happened there
they're trying to make
literally trying to do the same thing
that everyone is doing
trying to make a sale the sale went left
and he ended up with stab wounds
literally just for weed
when like it's not that important
like he could be making legal money or
nice money in a professional environment
and learning how to carry yourself
professionally
you've almost lost your life over a bag
of weed
remove them feet and then move them feet
good boy this boxing club teaches more
than just sport
disciplined dedication and the desire to
change for the better
it's a place for young people to go no
matter how desperate they are
sessions cost a pound but the fee is
waived regularly
i've been a firefighter for
and a half years
i've saved more lives in this boxing
club than i have ever done carrying out
a burning building this place genuinely
is saving lives he's saving their lives
again
it's you know it's so it's a
life-and-death situation
they have to make a split-second
decision in some circumstances
so and it's a junction where they go
left or right
training here gives abdul routine and
purpose but he knows people who have
taken a different path
it's easier said than done to leave it
obviously you can't just walk out of it
but i'd say you're saying try your best
to slowly make your way out of it i'm
saying because if you if you live that
way your whole life you're gonna end up
in prison or you know dead on the street
like in one side of something have you
got a little brother or sister yeah
imagine you have to look after them and
then you lost your job in anything and
you come to like bills are coming in you
had no money for food
real talk what did you do are you going
to look at your little sister starve or
if someone offered you you know you
could go tomorrow and get some bud and
move it what you going to do
every person i've spoken to says gang
life never ends well
we're on the way to matthew's brother
gary's gravesite
he was in a gang when he was stabbed to
death trying to steal drugs
the kind of choices young people are
making now
more than ever for quick cash
he's the guy that when i was young and
i'm emotional i'm crying he put his arm
around me and he bought me trainers when
he used to go basketball and the toe was
shown here by me trainers so you sold
drugs for his family
how old are you that more people will
end up dead
based on the pressures that the last few
months have have put on them and their
families
loads
kids are getting groomed at an
exceptional rate they're getting
exploited and like i'm saying some
parents know what's going on and they
either can't stop it they don't know
where to turn and in some cases they're
allowing it because that kid's bringing
in the income for that household
one crisis is causing another with
children in poverty breaking the law to
try and survive
they need a way out
shingi marike sky news